Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call. We're doing best to
enter your questions reminder to
look at any announcements on the member site
for anything that you may missed.
We did have a question about last week's Zoom call and see where it was at.
This was said, why was I not able? I want to jump to this one first. Why was I not able
to access some Zoom calls this last weekend? Last week's Zoom call wasn't up until last night
because I actually take that back. So last week's Zoom call was up right after
the Zoom call. For a couple days, and then we had an issue with our
video site. So our video site got hacked again. And sometimes you swear it's YouTube
tried to hack our video site because they don't want our videos getting out there, but
what else? I'm getting a little bit conspiratorial there. But our video site was down and then it
when we had to reset it to a dust and went in to reset it, he had to reset it back in time
prior to that Zoom call being up so that we didn't realize that that Zoom call that was deleted.
So last week's Zoom call didn't get up till last night. So I apologize that because he had to work
over the weekend to try to get our website, our video site back up. So that was a little bit of a hassle
and that threw off a lot of the Zoom call. A lot of the other videos of the site were not coming up
and we're coming up on WALKY. So that's what the issue with that was. Now that's corrected so you
can see last week's Zoom call up there. If you ever go to our video site and you see videos that are
coming up real WALKY or goofy or something's not coming up, please send us a message. Either email us
or send a message through the member site that that's happening because we're not on it every day.
So the times that it's gotten hacked several times and we may not catch it for several days until
somebody tells us so you could tell us. We appreciate that. So that's why that video or last little video
wasn't accessible. We apologize for that. Okay, first question. Why is it not good to take iodine?
I thought that it helped protect against radiation. I remember when the Chernobyl
scare happened with the damage to Chernobyl and I remember when the tsunami damaged the nuclear power plant in
Japan and a lot of nutritious were saying you should get iodine and start taking iodine because
radiation is going to be most damaging to your thyroid glands. So if you get radiation
through food that you're eating because it's some tainted food or radiation because of where you're
living and typically this was talking about people on the west coast as the waves of radiation
and radioactive waste was coming from Japan coming over the ocean to people in Alaska
and on the northwest United States. A lot of nutritious were saying to take iodine to protect your
thyroid. But there was a lot of information out about if there's ever a nuclear holocaust of any kind
it would be good to take iodine to protect your thyroid. And there is some truth to that.
Your thyroid needs iodine badly in order for it to produce its two made hormones. T4 and T3, T3 is
the act of thyroid hormone but it mainly produces T4 and that changes to the act of T3 in the gut.
And so it is dependent upon iodine and if there are other
radioactive minerals present it will have a predilection to go to the thyroid and replace
the it itself in place of iodine and it can cause thyroid cancer. So in the case of radiation
toxicity thyroid cancer is one of the more common cancers. So there is some truth if you're exposed
to radiation like in a nuclear holocaust taking some iodine can be helpful. However, taking iodine
exogenously we need outside of just what you would be getting in your food.
And typically that would be in the form of potassium iodine in supplements.
It can be harmful to your thyroid because too much iodine is going to increase the risk of
sparking an autoimmune attack on your thyroid. In fact, there are multiple studies that show that
people with hypothyroidism, primary hypothyroidism taking iodine because that was the old idea. You know,
back in from the 1960s on it was thought that you know iodine deficiency was a major cause of
hypothyroidism. And it thought that it can't be a piece of that but it isn't a major cause and it's
and with that theory, iodine supplementation was really pushed. It's still pushed by a lot of
uninformed nutritionalists and current factors and naturopaths. And it is causing Hashimoto so it
so of course you're going to have primary hypothyroidism that autoimmune thyroid. And take iodine
taking that that's going to help their thyroid. They can actually have some symptom relief by taking
iodine. If you can take the take the long, iodine for a prolonged period of time it can create an
immune attack on the thyroid. And there are studies that are shown that people that do that with
type of primary hypothyroidism 100% of the people, they have developed Hashimoto so that's an autoimmune
thyroid where you have elevated TPO or viral glowyland antibodies. So it's not recommending. So I do not
recommend people taking iodine supplementation for a prolonged period of time. Taking a short term
for different reasons is certainly makes sense. But taking it on for a prolonged period of time,
taking that you're doing good for your thyroid or going doing good to prevent any radioactive
attack on your thyroid is not really wise. So the struggle is you're trying to find a
mineral supplement. If you are trying to find a mineral supplement that doesn't have added potassium
iodine, it's very difficult out there. That effect where we private labels one that we can now no
longer get as of this week. And that was one of the only ones that was on the market that didn't have
that. Now there are a few other ones that don't have iodine. But I'm also thinking because I'm looking
for a mineral supplement that doesn't have iodine and doesn't have copper. So it's safe for my
cancer patients. Now there's a few that I would approve of that don't have iodine or have a
or are a food based mineral that may have a little bit of iodine, which is at a food base not at a
potassium iodine. And they have just a little bit of copper that's at a food base that isn't just
a copper supplementation that's added. So as we are scrambling to find the right
supplement for our patients for that, I do want to remind because we have a lot of patients that
don't necessarily follow my recommended and they're taking supplements that
don't really be here. Maybe I wouldn't approve of, but you're up to listen to me. But I'm just telling you
taking supplements, taking minerals with added copper. If it's not a food based like you're taking
greens first. Oh, that has copper in it. Yeah, but it's just food based. What would be in the food
you're eating? It's not added copper. Oh, it does have iodine. Yeah, but it's food based. It's not
added iodine. So if you're taking a mineral and you're paying for a mineral that's adding potassium iodine,
adding copper and you have cancer, you are increasing your risk of cancer growth because of the added
copper and you're increasing your risk of Hashimoto's because of the added iodine. So I just don't
think that's wise. So do beware of mineral supplements as a cancer patient. Even if you, oh,
my daughter takes this, she's not a cancer patient. So can she take can in copper? Well, yes, but copper
toxicity is also very common among non-cancer patients, especially when we look at your genetics,
many of you have, I've gone over your genetics and I've shown that you have issues with
seruloclasm, with other copper transport genes, which increases one's risk. So those are not
uncommon, but it increases one's risk for copper toxicity. So we're getting excess copper
and you're taking supplements with added copper. That increases one's risk for copper toxicity
because many people are sick deficient. So when they're not absorbing, they're taking zinc,
so they're having deficiency of zinc and they have excess copper and then you can get excess copper
in the tissue. It can be a cause of joint issues, muscle issues, arthritic problems, degenerative
joint issues, all sorts of cognitive issues, and general malaise and fatigue. So copper toxicity
is a real thing that you want to be aware of too. So even if you don't have cancer, I don't think
that a person should be taking a lot of excess copper. So that's thing to think about too. And
certainly, if you don't have cancer, you don't want to be taking iodine because you could end up
with thyroid issues and Hashimoto's is the number of one autoimmune disease currently going, but I
think a big part of that, or at least a piece of that has to do with the rhodious thought that
everybody should be taking iodine. So that's why. Next question. What is the best way to ensure
you get enough protein? Well, maybe a better question is what are the best, what are foods that
contain the most protein? Because you only get enough protein by consuming it. So you have to
consume foods that have protein in the best way to get proteins through eating animal product, animal
needs. So it's really very difficult to get enough protein, be it on a vegan diet. And certainly
for a cancer patient who needs even more protein, because remember, you need about a gram of protein
per pound of body weight. So if you weigh 150 pounds, it's best to consume about 150 grams of
protein a day. Well, that's difficult even if you're not a vegan. It's very difficult if you're
a vegan to consume 150 grams of protein a day in a non-beat source. So that's a challenge for everybody.
So that's typically when I recommend for somebody who has a diagnosis of cancer, if you don't have a
diagnosed cancer, you could probably do it with less than that. But remember, cancer patients
need protein consumption in order to make the subset of lymphocytes, natural killer cells and T cells
that are responsible for killing cancer cells. So you need to get that protein. So it's hard to get that
with just a vegan diet you have to eat meat. This person asked a second question, can I add protein
powder to my daily drink, if so, which one is best? Yes, you can. So the best one I think we've
sculpted the market on this is also the clearest one. And it has the lowest amount of glutamated,
which is the U.S. enzymes brand. Same price as the other ones at the market. So it's not any more
expensive, but it's the clearest one out there. It doesn't have, it's tested for chemicals,
or source material, as well as it has the lowest amount of glutamate. They make it in a chocolate
variety, in a vanilla variety, and everybody that takes it has sent their moment. So I think that's
the best one to do. Now, you got to remember, you're only going to get about 20, 25 grams of protein,
couple of scoops of protein powder. So it's still not, you know, if you're drinking a daily drink,
anyhow, you might as well throw some of that in there so you're getting some protein. But that's not
going to be a substitute for you eating, eating animal meat. So I'll just remember that. So U.S. enzymes,
we have it on our store. Why wasn't unable to access the Zoom calls last week and I answered that one
because our site was hacked and done. It took a couple days to get that back up and going. So
and then we had to put the last Zoom call back up there. So I apologize for that. If I have surgery
to remove both breasts, cancer is ER positive. So this person is ER positive. Estrogen receptor
positive breast cancer. They're going to have a double mastectomy. Do I still need to take
natural rheumatase inhibitor? The answer is yes. And you think, well, I'm having the cancer removed.
So the cancer was in my breast. Let's say, and I don't know, but let's pretend that
person in a PET scan was only localized in the breast. There was no
positive signs of the cancer being anywhere else in the body. Not the lymph nodes, nothing.
So you're going to remove the cancer. So you're debulking the cancer. No, not debulking it. I'm
removing it completely. Well, the thing is, is that long before you were ever diagnosed with cancer,
you have circulated tumor cells. And those are also ER positive, most likely. So they're still going
to be rolled to having estrogen attached to the estrogen beta receptor and have it locked in
poptosis. So you still want to do an aerobotase inhibitor. If you're going to an ecologist,
and you're following your ecologist's recommendations, then they would be recommended. You stay on
their natural, they're not natural. The aerobotase inhibitor medication. And people will go,
why do I need to do that when I'm having my breast ribbons? Same question. Because
you still have circulating tumor cells elsewhere in the body, just because it didn't show up on a PET scan.
What does that mean? I don't have cancer anywhere else. It means that you don't have cancer larger than
three million cells large. So if you have cancer that's 300,000 cells large, it's not going to show up
on a PET scanner, CT scanner, MRI. You're not going to be palpating it. You're not going to know
that it's growing or the bone. You just have to assume that that possibility exists, not that
you're trying to be negative-mally, but you have to be, you know, you have to be a realist.
And so you still do the things that's like, okay, if I'm going to have my pulse breast ribbons,
I have to keep using it the right. Well, of course you do. If I have to keep eating right,
of course you do. If you'll get oncologists that say, no, you don't have to do that. Oh, you're
at a clean bill of health. And then all of a sudden the cancer comes back with the
vengeance sitting here. We'll never get back with the vengeance. It was never completely gone.
And you pretended it was. So you have to continue treated it as it. So yes, you still have to take
it. Next question. Can you explain why we should not just take all our supplements at one time
during the day. It is easiest for me to take them all in the morning because, okay, so there's certain
supplements that you could do that. So your fat-soluble supplements, your vitamin A, your vitamin D,
your vitamin K, your vitamin E. You don't have to split those up. They're their fat-soluble,
they'll stay in your system for a much longer period of time. You don't have to break those up
during the day. But your other vitamins, your other minerals, your other nutrients that are like
herbals, they have a half life in your body. So if you took them all in the morning and let's say
the half life was in hour, or you took 100 milligrams of it, that means in an hour you only, let's say
you absorb 100 milligrams of that supplement. In an hour you only have 50 milligrams. In another hour,
you have 25 milligrams. Another hour, you have 12.5 milligrams, equals like that. So by seven,
you took them at seven o'clock in the morning, by seven o'clock at night, you have nothing in your system.
Now, if that's the only way you can take your supplements and you're just being a realist with your
own self, and you just cannot remember just to take them at night, then biomeans just take them
once during the day. But it is always best, other than your fat soluble supplements, to break them up.
The only other supplements that I'd say, you don't have to do that with is if you're taking a binder,
that would be a supplement that I say, take that in the afternoon, 30 minutes from food, or in the morning,
30 minutes from food, that's a binder. So that's that. You're not splitting that up, try to keep that
in circulation. You're keeping that in the gut, when you're trying to bind things in the gut. So
that's different. Or taking a digestive enzyme that you're taking with a meal, that's different.
You take that with your meal. You're taking HCl and digestive enzymes with each meal, because you want
it to be there when you're eating. But if you're trying to kill cancer cells with an herbal supplement,
you're just taking that general vitamin or whatever. It has a half light. So the more you are able
to split it up, let's tell people, like, I could do morning and night. That's only two doses.
Is that okay? Yeah, that's better. And some of you are just fantastic at, oh, I just
set my alarm, but I just have my supplements with me and I developed this little system and I have
them in these little coaches. And when I take them every three hours, well, that's great. But some
people can't do that. So just be honest with yourself and do the best. But there is a reason behind
the badness that sometimes if you understand the reason, you could be a little bit better at
disciplining yourself to do that. So that helps. Next question. How effective is RIF when a person is
dealing with two different forms of cancer? Well, it's just as effective, except it has to be
programmed the right way. So I can, well, currently, I think I have at least to happen as the people
have two completely, have two completely different types of cancer. Now, that's pretty rare. So it's,
it's really kind of interesting that I have that many people with that. So,
now you can have two different types of breast cancer. Well, that's, that's really easy because
when a person, I don't program the right specifically to a type of breast cancer because I
have said this to every breast cancer patient that I personally, there's not that I don't trust
some pathologists with their eye on a microscope diagnosing the type of breast cancer.
It's just that I don't trust every pathologist behind that. It's easy. It still could be
human error and they could make a mistake in their, they could be off. So, okay, we have eight hours
every night of programming. I'm putting in all the frequencies for every type of breast cancer.
So, so if you have two different types of breast cancer, it doesn't make any difference.
You're getting all the types of breast cancer in your phone grid.
If you had, let's say if you had two different types of brain cancer, we've have, we've had people with
a glioma, which is technically a brain tumor, but it could be, it's now graded and it can become an
aggressive grade and be considered a cancer. And they might have an astrocytoma so they can have a
glioma and an astrocytoma. Actually, they have a patient that has that. Well, then there's specific
frequencies for astrocytoma. And I put that into that. I also put frequencies in for glioma. So,
they, that person is running those frequencies every night for both those types of cancer.
So, is the right effective if you have two different types of cancer? Yes. I also have couples
like the husband has prostate cancer and the wife has breast cancer. So, they sleep in in the same
bed in there and they can't afford to get two rifes. So, we put both their programs on the same
rife. And then we, we just time it the right way. So, if they're communicating with a couple, maybe the
husband goes to bed earlier as he gets up early for work and the wife goes to bed a little later. So,
her programs are later in the evening if his programs are earlier in the evening. So, we just
time it that way. So, it's very easy to do. The rife is only effective as effective as the frequencies
that you're running. So, if you don't have a program directly to the cancer, it's just not going to work.
I remember the rife isn't this magic wand. It's going to cure everybody. But it's going to be the
most effective on killing pathogens. And it's going to be the most effective on killing cancer.
Again, with everybody's rife machine, I program it with everything you could think of. So, it has
frequencies in there for pain and frequencies in there for information and such. And we have people that
have given great testimonies that they work. But, you know, that's not really where the rife shines
perfectly. The rife isn't the only tool that you would use for things like that, for sure.
And a person the other day that tell me they didn't want to say it on the zoom call, but they used
the rife for something other than cancer or pathogens. I think it was for pain or anxiety or something.
But she said it really didn't work. And she didn't want to say it on the zoom call, because she
didn't want me to feel bad. That makes me feel bad. I don't have my faith in the rife machine.
I have my faith in God. And we have to use things wisely. So, just like I injured my knee again,
because I have a partial tariff on to my mediscus that I refuse to go in and get surgery
because I'm just stubborn of a man. So, I, you know, I injured it actually about three years ago,
playing soccer with the grandkids foolishly. And I used the rife on it and it really helped,
but I also used PEMF. I also used laser. So, you use other tools as well as they're appropriate. So,
you're trying to heal anxiety, you're trying to heal, you know, a muscular skeletal injury.
Certainly, you have the rife. Use it. But it doesn't mean that you don't use other tools.
So, you know, I have a workshop in my bar and I have all sorts of tools, drills, and saws,
and hammers. And you use them where they're most appropriately, you know, geared for. So,
you just have to understand that you could get a screw in with a hammer, but it's a lot
better to use your screwdriver than it is to use your hammer. So, you want to try to use things
appropriately. But you're trying to deal with cancer. The rife is the most effective tool as far
as killing the cancer by far compared to any other modality out there in my opinion. If you're
trying to kill pathogens, like in the case of Lyme disease or chronic viral infections,
and things like that, the rife is the best tool. But let's say if I've got a patient that comes
to me and they say, I don't have cancer, I don't have Lyme disease, I don't have any chronic
infections, but I have this toxicity. And I've had it tested and this is my whole issue is this
toxicity. Should I get my rife machine? Well, the rife machine will help because it will help with
the liver, because it can help the liver heal and help the liver function better. But really,
you need to be doing some different detox things. You need to follow my seven phase of detox. You need
to make sure you're having moments. You need to be doing coffee. And as you need to be doing liver
flushes, you need to be doing. There's lots of other things you need to do. So, that's the idea
of just using tools correctly. All of them can be a benefit, but you use what's going to be
best. I get lots of questions on case reviews. I'm thinking I have cancer and I'm thinking of getting
hyperbaric chamber or I'm thinking to get a rife. What do you think I should get? Well, if you can
afford to get both by all means, I'm on paper. If you have a entire therapy suite in your house. But
what would I pick first? Definitely a rife. Well, then should I pick, I can afford a hyperbaric.
Should I get that next? Well, it depends on what type of cancer you have. If you have brain
cancer, well, then I don't say maybe that would be next. If you have breast cancer, no, then maybe
the next thing would be a hyperthermia. So hyperthermia would be great for breast cancer,
or pancreatic cancer, or liver cancer, but not for brain cancer. So it depends on the type
of cancer you have. What would be the next best tool if you could afford it? So,
you know, or if you could afford to go to a practitioner, you know, some practitioner has a
hyperbaric unit. So that's what he had here. She has, so he's hard selling them and buying a package
of hyperbaric chamber. And this person has, you know, prostate cancer or liver cancer or breast
cancer. I'm sorry, it's not going to do a whole lot for that. If you had brain cancer, then yes,
go spend the sessions on there. But again, using tools properly and honestly is always the best
thing I think for a practitioner. And for you as a patient to be educated in what tools would be best.
So don't ever feel bad about asking me out, be honest with you. I have all the tools. I have my therapy
junkie. But, you know, it's just going to be honest, I guess. You don't recommend things just because
that's what you have to sell. And that's what you get a lot out there on the internet these days
is a lot of dishonesty in sales. So just be aware. Okay, first question from the chat,
should I be taking methylcobolamine B12 as a cancer patient? In general, no, you shouldn't.
So methylcobolamine is a form of B12. So remember, the main forms of B12 out there are
the inorganic form called cyanocobolamine, which is not good and I don't recommend for anybody.
Then you got hydroxylcobolamine and adenosylcobolamine, which don't have methyl groups.
Or it's bound to a methyl group that is called methylcobolamine. So these are all forms of B12.
Well, I heard that people should be taking methylcobolamine because that helps with the NGHF,
RG defect. Well, yeah, it can help with the NGHF, but if you have cancer,
methyl groups can silence tumor suppressor genes so they can block the intrinsic
a poptonic pathway, meaning that inside the cell, you have a pathway stimulated by what are
called tumor suppressor genes that will stimulate cell death when a cancer, when a cell is going
to rapid replication, aka is being cancerous. So when you got a cell that's acting as it's cancer,
meaning it's rapidly replicating, your tumor suppressor gene should kick it and kill the cell.
Well, methyl groups block that, methyl groups attached to that gene and turn that gene off.
So it allows for the cancer to continue to grow. So cancer patients should not be taking methyl
folate. You'll see it on a label as methyl tetrahedral folate or methyl folate.
You'll, or they should not be taking methylcobolamine. That'll be only
exception to that is if a person has unablaed test elevated homocysteine. So if a person has
normal homocysteine levels and they have a diagnosis of cancer, they should not be taking excess
methyl groups. If they have, well, what if they have an MTHFR defect? It doesn't make any
difference. If you have cancer and you have a normal homocysteine, you should not be taking methyl folate,
nor should you be taking methylcobolamine. Well, then they're not detoxified because the MTHFR gene
has got defects on it. No, no. So does the MTHFR gene help with detoxification? Yes. There's a lot
of other detox pathways. Taking excess methyl groups are going to silence genes. They're also going
to do other things too. So you'd never just recommend any practitioners are listening. You'd never
just recommend methyl groups because the person has an MTHFR gene defect. You have to look at all
the genes. If they have defects in their biopterate pathway, you're going to strongly push that pathway
as well. You could have all sorts of mood issues as well. Only caveat to that is if a person has
excess homocysteine, then we're going to have to take methyl groups for a short period of time.
Next question from the chat. Which program in the right is for liver detox? There is only one liver
support in its only 15 minutes. Is that enough to detox the liver? Remember, go back to you have
access to the seven phases of detox. Don't think that your liver isn't detoxing. So what are some
programs that can help support liver detox? There is a, you have it true, right? The person who
asked this question, there is a detox program in your foot bath, your eye on the pro-way. There's a
detox program in the frequency folder as well. I can't think of the name of what it does. It is called
detox. So look at that. That can help with liver detox. And again, is the right going to be
your main tool to detox the liver? No, it's not. So that's not your main tool to detox the liver.
Your main tool to detox your liver is going to be, well, number one, try to decrease your
toxic load, your toxicity input. And then you're working on your phase six, phase five,
phase four, then three, two, one. And that's going to be mainly through chemistry,
mainly through nutrition. Next question from the chat. Should I be taking BAM also? So for those that
don't know because I don't recommend BAM a lot for cancer patients, BAM is our powder supplement that
we make. That's called that we name BAM because I named it for brain anti-inflammatory mix. But it's
actually not just for brain, though it does have a luthral root end, which is good for the brain.
But the rest of the things are just anti-inflammatory things, which is good for your whole body. So
can a cancer patient take BAM? Oh, absolutely. Yes. So there's nothing in there that a cancer patient
should take. So yes, you can take that as well. So that doesn't mean that everybody listens to this
and they're like, oh, I want BAM too. Why don't I have BAM? Let me get BAM. Where do I get BAM? What's
that? No. So but this person has that for their spouse, so they certainly can add that to their
mix as well. So Scott's a good anti-inflammatory things in it in a mix. At that time when I created that
really wasn't anything on the market. And you know, that was 15, 20 years ago when I developed that.
So we just made it ourselves. So we just never stopped. So all right, I'll try to get this
right away. And so if anybody asked a question, some people asked questions that maybe we're going
to get some. I think they're separating away so we can see this. All right. God bless everybody.
And have a great week and we'll see you next week. Bye-bye.